je dois te demander pardon pardon ma
chérie pardon pardon pardon mais donc
vous vous retrouvez plutôt vous Mireille
dans ce portrait que l'on fait de vous
de grande amoureuse aimant les hommes
grande séductrice ououi oui oui oui oui
oui j'adore ça vous adorez ça oui oui
j'adore les hommes j'adore la conquête
aussi de l'homme oui et puis j'aime
aimer j'aime qu'on mêe
j'aime j'aime les la
complicité j'aime vivre avec un homme et
et vous avez toujours été aussi dans
cette dévotion j'allais dire de l'homme
parce que quand même j'ai repris une
phrase de vous qui est absolument
saisissante vous dites que vous vous
identifiez plus jeune à Marie Madeleine
quand elle lave les pieds de Jésus et
qu'elle les parfume avant de les essuyer
avec ses longs cheveux oui mais c'était
c'était d' dont je parlais là vous avez
pris une phrase qui s'adressait à donc
si vous voulez c'était au milieu de de
tout toutes les femmes qui étaient
autour de lui je je à cette époque- làà
j'ai eu envie si vous voulez de
m'occuper d'un homme Alain était le
premier homme avec qui j'ai vécu et
j'avais tellement d'admiration pour lui
et j'en ai toujours beaucoup que je me
sentais si vous voulez sa servante mais
en même temps j'étais sa femme et
j'étais son amante je ve dire pour moi
c'était j'étais tout et et et j'aime
bien ce ce le fait d'être
d'être tout pour quelqu'un c'est
incroyable ce que vous dites servante
Avante c'est une sorte de Gat oui mais
pourquoi pas oui bien sûr et on peut se
sacrifier pour mais c'est pas
sacrifieré du tout alors absolument pas
je prends mon plaisir à ça mais
qu'est-ce que vous attendiez d'un homme
vous Mireille j'attendais je sais pas
lorsque j'ai rencontré Alain Delon
j'avais envie d'une famille j'avais
envie d'enfant j'avais envie de
la célébrité je l'avais mais j'attendais
tout la découverte le monde les
voyages savoir ce que c'était que que
d'avoir une maison de m'occuper d'une
maison d'avoir des des amis d'être
maîtresse de maison voilà tout ça et je
l'ai découvert à travers lui c'est vrai
et vous cherchiez l'amour total
absolu vous y croyez ou pas l'amour
absolu c'était difficile avec
j'avais le plus bel homme du monde c'est
vrai il fallait faire ça place fallait
arriver petit à petit donc pas tellement
jalouse finalement oh ça ça m'a passé
alors vous pouvez pas vivre avec Alain
et être jalouse et vaut mieux affronter
les problèmes de face donc est-ce que
vous vous êtes dit c'est cet amour dont
j'ai manqué que je n'ai pas eu de la
part de donc du premier homme de votre
vie de la vie de tout le monde qui est
le père est-ce que vous êtes dit que
c'était ça aussi que vous cherchiez
auprès des hommes m ou jamais alors je
n'ai pas cherché un père avec Al je n'ai
pas cherché che un père avec aucun homme
que j'ai rencontré mais j'en ai rêvé
j'ai rêvé si vous voulez d'un père c'est
vrai j'ai rechercher toute ma vie un
amour voilà pour moi l'amour c'est c'est
ces deux bras qui m'en serrent comme ça
et qui me sert très fort
contre contre sa poitrine et c'est cette
place là que j'ai toujours cherché et
que vous n'avez pas connu étant enfant
non et c'est pas celllà non plus que
vous avez quand vous rencontrez un homme
se doute que ça peut ne pas être éternel
est-ce qu'avec avec un père vous êtes
protégé moi j'ai jamais été protégé j'ai
toujours été un petit un petit soldat
qui est monté à l'attaque c'est comme ça
que vous voyez
euhou alors mir c'est donc finalement la
première fois hein que vous parlez
réellement vous dites je suis
aujourd'hui certaine que mon père
n'était pas mon père ce père donc qui ne
vous a pas aimé vous dites je je suis
sûre que cet homme ne m'a pas aimé et
que je lui ai posé un problème je et que
c'est pas de sa faute qu'il ne m'ait pas
aimé je pense qu'il y avait derrière
derrière cette histoire quelque chose
qui faisait qu'il ne pouvait pas m'aimer
et ça je le ressens je l'ai ressenti de
plus en plus fort alors quels sont les
indices Mireille qui vous ont amené à
penser dans votre enfance qui n'était
pas votre père qu'il se passait quelque
chose qui n'était pas dans norm dans
votre
relation je devais avoir 7 ans et et cet
homme m'a amené un soir un jour au
grenier avec et il m'a dit voilà je vais
me pendre et je vais me pendre à cause
de toi et je l'ai supplié je lui ai dit
je t'en supplie je je je je ne veux pas
je veux pas ça j'ai crié j'ai pleuré
c'est terrible oui non mais c'est
terrible et c'est terrible parce que
pour que cet homme arrive à me dire ça
c'est qu'il était dans un état de
souffrance terrible
aussi il je crois qu'il pouvait pas
faire autrement que de me faire mal donc
plus j'y pensais et plus je me disais
c'est pas possible c'est pas mon père il
y a eu un problème il y a eu quelque
chose mais c'est pas mon père mais à 7
ans comment vous avez réagi ah bah c ans
vous vous commencez par oublier tout ça
vous l'évitez vous vous passez à côté
vous vous débrouillez pour vivre faire
le moin de bruit possible devant lui
vous osez pas en parler à votre mère
parce que parce que vous vous avez peur
de faire mal vous avez peur de faire de
la peine vous dites que votre père ne
savait pas comment vous appeler
c'està-dire que mon
père dès que j'étais seul et que je
passais près de lui je
l'entendais groger un peu bâtarde bâarde
la bâarde ah c'est ça qui disait il me
disait La bâarde Bâtarde quand vous avez
7 ans vous savez pas ce que c'est
bâtarde c'est c'est un peu aussi ça qui
qui qui qui a tourné dans ma tête bien
sûr parce que c'est quand même un mot
très fort on dit pas ça à sa fille oui
si on n'est pas soi-même profondément
malheureux blessé dans son honneur
blessé voilà exactement puis vous
grandissez puis un jour où vous prenez
un peu plus de force et vous pouvez vous
éloigner un peu et exister respirer
d'une autre manière et et votre mère
elle vous donnait de l'amour
euh oui mais c'était différent aussi
voilà c'est votre mère oui elle est
belle quand vous la voyez ben elle est
très belle moi j'ai manqué de j'ai
manqué de bras voilà j'ai manqué de de
de de de cette de cette manière de de
prendre les les êtres contre soi ma mère
n'avait pas envie de m'avoir auprès
d'elle mais vous lui avez posé des
questions vous étant enfant enfant
adulte adulte et et là je je commençais
un peu à harceler ma mère et lui dire
mais dis-moi dis-moi dis-moi dis-moi
dis-moi dis-moi la
vérité tu as rencontré un autre homme tu
as tu as eu une histoire d'amour avec
quelqu'un ma mère tu es folle ou quoi
arrête de me parler comme ça donc ma
mère était mais outrée quand je lui
parlais et je l'ai eu très âgée chez moi
elle devait avoir presque 90 ans et donc
moi aussi j'étais grande j'étais déjà
oui oui je lui disais maman mais dis-moi
on va pas on va pas rester et ma mère
me disait absolument pas tu es la fille
de ton père point on n parle plus mais
peut-être que vous êtes la fille de
votre père vous n'y croyez pas non alors
malgré la négation totale de votre mère
quel est l'élément qui a fait que tout à
coup vous avez su ce n'était pas votre
père qu'est-ce qui vous a remis en
marche je me suis retrouvée un jour sur
les ChampsÉlysées allit acheter un un CD
parce que je partais en vacances et j'ai
rencontré cré quelqu'un qui était un
écrivain et qui m'a dit qui était au
téléphone et qui m'a dit mire j'ai une
amie au téléphone qui souhaiterait vous
parler et il m'a donné son numéro de
téléphone il m'a dit si vous avez
l'occasion de l'appeler appelez-la et
j'ai appelé cette personne qui m'a dit
oui bonjour en effet j'ai une un message
pour vous d'un seul coup je me suis
retrouver avec cette femme et je lui dis
mais qui êtes-vous
elle m'a dit ben voilà je m'appelle
Patricia
et j'ai un message pour vous de votre
maman et je lui ai dit mais ma maman est
morte il y a 10 ans m'a dit je sais mais
j'ai un message pour vous donc une
médium c'est une médium qui reçoit des
messages et là elle m'a dit écoutez
voilà posez-moi des questions je me mets
en communication avec votre maman et
vous aviez déjà eu à faire des
médiums jamais non et vous c'est un
moment Mireille juste pour comprendre
parce que c'est vrai que c'est c'est
difficile d'en parler parce que ça
semble un peu hallucinant c'estile pour
moi j'imagine mais vous pensiez à ce
moment-là beaucoup à justement à à votre
père qui n'était peut-être pas votre
père pas du tout pas du tout et ma mère
m'a m'a demandé pardon et je me suis
entendu au téléphone parler à cette
femme et de lui dire maman alors que je
croyais que de ma vie je ne prononcerai
plus ce mot et d'un seul coup oui maman
j'entendais cette femme qui me
disait qui parlait avec un peu la voix
de ma mère et qui me disait je dois te
demander pardon je dois te demander
pardon pardon ma chérie pardon pardon
pardon et je lui disais mais mais bien
sûr mais bien sûr mais bien sûr je te
pardonne mais bien sûr mais de quoi
enfin je te demande pardon voilà et et
j'ai quitté cette femme euh en larme
bien sûr et tout ça par téléphone par
téléphone et alors je suis rentrée de
vacances et j'ai été voir Patricia
et là j'ai rencontré une femme qui m'a
tout de suite séduite elle a elle a 50
ans elle est belle elle est elle est
normale elle a un petit garçon et elle
reçoit des
messages et puis au bout d'un an un jour
elle m'appelle elle m'a dit bah tu sais
j'ai un autre truc pour toi
euh il paraît que ton père est marin que
ton père était marin et là alors la tête
la terre m'est tombé sur la tête c'est
vrai que c'est un peu ah c'est très très
très particulier trou non non non elle
est de moi commeêes là ça elle a elle a
un pendule elle se met un petit peu en
avant comme ça et puis elle ne me
regarde pas je lui parle et elle me
répond comme elle devient elle devient
un canal en fait et et elle a elle a mon
père en direct voilà mais quand elle est
rentre en communication avec donc
justement ce fameux Edmon qui est
marinou qui serait donc votre père et
vous vous dites à un moment donné est-ce
que je peux t'appeler papa oui oui tu
peux je l'ai tellement espéré je ne veux
pas que tu penses que je t'ai abandonné
je t'ai toujours suivi alors vous
demandez toujours à Patricia qui se fait
l'écho de la voix de cet homme est-ce
que tu m'as connu enfant je t'ai vu une
fois bébé puis ta mère n'a plus voulu
elle avait trop peur que ça sache et
comment vous vous êtes rencontré vous
allez jusque- là et là on vous dit nous
sommes croisés rue d'Alger un matin ta
mère courit elle a laissé tomber son sac
avec son porte-monnaie ses papiers ses
crayons et je l'ai aidé à tout ramasser
mais c'était elle parlait cette Patricia
avec autant de détails elle vous donnait
oui exactement exactement j'ai tout
enregistré et physiquement vous le voyez
vraiment vous avez physiquement oui je
sais qu'il a il avait des yeux
kakis puisque c'est lui qui me l'a dit
comme vous comme moi exactement oui
et et je crois qu'il était plaisait
beaucoup aux femmes donc un bel homme je
pense qu'il était très très très très
beau très beau mais dites donc vous
n'êtes pas en train de me décrire
regardez-moi l'homme idéal dans le fond
c'était mon
père et oui bien sûr bien sûr c'est ça
l'homme idéal pour vous bien sûr mais il
avait des bras ouverts voilà oui c'est
ce qui est important oui et il savait
dire je t'aime je me sens très heureuse
avec avec cette image et à partir de là
donc nécessité envie de mener ah ben
j'aié une enquête bien sûr d'abord j'ai
étis à
Toulon j'aiétaéis essayé de retrouver
tout le
parcours de ma mère et de mon père et et
en plus je sais qu'il était
sous-officier je sais je sais un TR TR
de trucs sur lui donc alors ce qui est
incroyable aussi c'est que vous n'avez
pas retrouver sa trace tout ce que vous
dites c'est Patricia cette médium qui
vous l'a dit qu' est mort en Indochine
au Tonquin voilà en 1945 45 au moment où
les les Japonais ont ont envahi et tué
tout toutes les troupes françaises non
j'ai pas retrouvé grand-chose mais vous
savez je je ne cherche pas une identité
mirireel c'est voilà c'est ce que je
voulais vous demander est-ce que c'est
pas c'est pas un nom que je cherche
c'est pas ça du tout je cherche
simplement à être en paix avec avec ma
vie avec avec mon intériorité et
aujourd'hui je suis en pai avec tout le
monde c'està-dire que je suis en paix
avec avec Marcelle parce que je
comprends qu'il a dû énormément souffrir
de jalousie donc pour pour qu'on
comprenne parce que c'est une avent
c'est un adultère on va dire banal aussi
qui a duré on sait pas combien de temps
quelques mois mais très très peu je
pense que ça a été une question de de de
3 ou 4 mois et vous comprenez le le
silence de votre mère maintenant à
distance
oui si Marc l'avait mis à la porte elle
n'avait plus rien plus rien donc elle se
dit il m'a pas privé de mes enfants il a
accepté je lui dois quelque chose
c'était l'esprit de l'époque aussi et
votre père alors il vous fait toujours
peur quand quand vous voyez la photo oui
oui mais mais plus de la même manière
donc qui est votre père maintenant dans
votre tête c'est Edmond ou c'est Marcell
c'est non c'est non ah c'est le père
biologique pour vous parce que souvent
on dit c'est le père qui est élevé
c'estement mon père et donc Marcelle qui
est-ce non c'est c'est c'est le père qui
m'a élevé mais mais disons que Edmond
m'a porté ses bras aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je sais que ses bras étaient
là comment vous savez ça je le sens j'ai
toujours senti d'abord j'ai jamais senti
que j'étais seule dans la vie je pense
que j'ai été une enfant de l'amour je le
sens en fond de moi c'est pas possible
que je sois aussi passionné que j'aime
autant les hommes et que et que ça
vienne de nulle part vous ne pensez pas
qu'il aurait pu se produire ça entre
Marcelle et votre mère non non non c'est
pas une histoire banale c'est pas une
histoire facile à
accepter j'ai toujours l'impression
d'être au téléphone avec quelqu'un
j'entends je vous pose la question parce
que c'est vrai que quand on ne se
reconnaît pas dans ses parents parfois
on se dit ce n'est pas possible je je ne
peux pas être leur enfant il y a
quelqu'un d'autre il y a quelque chose
souvent c'est un c'est un désir d'enfant
c'est vrai mais en même temps on
m'apporte une solution et on m'apporte
un message et on me dit mais pas une
preuve scientifique mais est-ce qu'on en
a vraiment besoin non moi j'ai pas
besoin de ça alors votre mari Pascal
desprè oui justement nous avons eu envie
de savoir comment il percevait tout cela
he oui bien sr vous voulez bien qu'on
l'écoute bien sûr on n'avait jamais
parlé de cette histoire avec avec son
celui qui qu'elle appelait son papa
cette fameuse scène incroyable enfin moi
j'ai j'ai découvert j'ai découvert sa
vie enfin surtout à travers ces deux
livres on n pas
elle est très pudique mais il y avait
aussi une chose qui me qui qui était qui
me faisait mal chez Mireille c'est que
elle avait pas
d'enfant et euh j'en avais et puis
euh voilà j'ai aussi envie de lui donner
une famille parce que maintenant depuis
depuis on a des petits enfants je crois
même sans doute que c'est la plus belle
chose que j'ai faite de ma vie c'est de
donner des petits enfants à mireidar qui
n'avaient pas pu avoir d'enfants et oui
c'est beau c'est un mec fabuleux et
c'était vraiment important justement de
recréer cette famille comme le dit votre
époux de vous donner ça des enfants des
petits enfants j'en ai toujours eu envie
j'en ai toujours envie j'ai pas pu avoir
d'enfant à cause du du cœur avec
problème du cœur bien sûr et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai des petits enfants
qui m'appellent mimi et qui me courent
après qui me sautent dessus et qui me
qui me serrent dans leurs bras et ça
j'en ai besoin ça ça revient sans arrêt
ce geste incroyable que vous faites sans
arrêt ce besoin de d'être serré dans les
bras c'est vrai et de serrer aussi les
autres ah oui là maintenant j'ai mes
petits enfants je les ser je les serre
je leur dis que je les aime je crois
qu'on dit jamais assez qu'on aime les
êtres alors vous savez je réalise
quelque chose mire
vous voulez me ramener je sais à Edmond
mais non c'est que vous parlez bien de
votre famille vos petits enfants qui ne
sont pas des enfants ni des petits
enfants biologiques or précédemment vous
m'avez fait l'éloge de la biologie vous
me dites c'est Edmond mon père parce que
c'est Edmond qui le père biologique
alors que regardez votre amour va c'est
une question de sentiment c'est une
question de sentiment si vous si
quelqu'un vous aime si quel quelun vous
vous vous sentez que que que vous êtes
important dans la vie de quelqu'un c'est
pas possible de ne pas l'aimer je pense
que j'aurais aimé Marcel si Marcel
m'avait ouvert ses bras il me les a pas
ouverts donc donc'est pas la biologie
c'est l'amour c'est l'amour bien sûr que
c'est l'amour cette histoire on vient
d'entendre votre époux hein disait que
vous Navier pas vraiment parler
finalement vous êtes resté toujours très
punique sur le sujet et avec les hommes
de votre vie est-ce que vous en avvez
parlé pas du tout non j'en ai jamais
parlé à Alain c'est quelque chose de de
fort c'est quelque chose qui m'habite et
qui vient de loin et j'ai j'ai pas envie
qu'on qu'on ne me croit pas si on me
croit pas je j'ai envie de me de me
battre et j'essaie de de convaincre
personne attendez non mais c'est ça que
je trouve beau dans votre histoire c'est
que cette histoire vous elle me convient
très très bien je suis bien je je suis
comme un poisson sont dans l'eau je suis
heureuse j'ai aujourd'hui j'ai un un
père j'ai une mère que je que j'adore et
puis j'ai un homme qui s'appelle Marcel
qui m'a élevé voilà et je lui pardonne
je crois que c'est ça le plus important
dans tout ce que vous dites c'est que
c'est une façon de faire la paix d'être
mais les messages je les ai reçus hein
ah oui non mais je ne je je ne mets rien
en doute de ce que vous avez vous vécu
tout tout est tout tout tout tout tout
est en place
tout le monde s'est mis en place tout va
bien je sais je sais qui je suis je sais
où sont où sont les êtres qui m'ont aimé
ou aidé ou voilà
et ma vie est belle merci
beaucoup pour ne rien manquer sur ma
chaîne Inna Mireille Duma abonnez-vous
et activez la
[Musique]
cloche